Locals in Mexico City do not only appreciate the Manuel Gea Gonzalez Hospital for its beauty,...
...they are also indebted to its designers for its ability to help purify the air...
...in one of the most polluted towns on earth.
Designed by Berlin-based Elegant Embellishments, the 2,500 square meter facade...
...is constructed from Prosolve modules.
These are coated with a special pigment which, when hit by ambient ultraviolet light,...
...reacts with urban air pollutants, breaking them down into less noxious compounds...
...like carbon dioxide and water.
The pigment itself remains unchanged, which means the modules can keep purifying the air...
...for up to a decade or until their coating wears off.
With a technology like ours, the great thing is you put a Prosolve facade somewhere...
...and it may not lower the macro levels of air pollution...
...for a place like Mexico City right away,...
...but what it can do is lower the levels in having a direct and local effect on the ground.
Elegant Embellishments have already used Prosolve in small structures...
...placed inside a shopping center in Perth, Australia,...
...and are currently working on a hotel project in Abu Dhabi.